i want to know how close to  encapsulating the notion of thinking  like a monk  can you get like how like if you were to  give somebody just a nutshell notion  of what that means what would you say  i'd say it means to live a life  in alignment and what that means  is that you live a life where what you  think what you say  and what you do are aligned with your  truest self  and what i mean by your truest self is  the self that was not given to you by  your parents  or by your education or by media or  movies  or not the self that you've created to  function in the world  so i think if you strip away all of  those  expectations obligations and opinions  what you're left with if you live in  alignment with that then you're thinking  like a monk